good morning Millennials welcome back to
the mornin toast
Thursday's episode right Thursday's
episode this week like time knows no
bounds goes by so slowly we have Morgan
Stewart host of daily pop and nightly
pop joining us a little bit later on the
show and we are obsessed with her the
toasters are obsessed with her we're
gonna convince her to get a Morgan
Stewart sport code for the toasters as
you guys know for Nick dials um
essential oils yeah there's a code we're
just getting codes for and we're gonna
get one for Morgan Stewart that is our
mission today in addition to doing what
we were born to do yeah she is totally a
dream guest like for this show yeah
she's also like a career goal for us and
for so many young men and women out
there
our young journalists I feel as though
growing up like everyone used to say I
want to be like Giuliana Rancic yes and
now I imagine like kidsí sees her like I
want to be like Morgan Stewart they
argue that is so well said I want to
host across the board on e I want to be
funny hilarious stylish and beautiful
and just be paid all for being myself
all at the same damn time she's she's
just so glam you guys we have a snitch
cam today we have a situation
sweet welcome counselor snitch yesterday
we could hear you today we can see you
it's a revelation it's almost like we
have some snitch on the toast a snitch
on the toast it's been so long saying
that to those sick last few episodes why
you guys haven't seen me in a long time
well the hashtag to us tell a thank you
for having me I haven't been here this
whole time buggers been here all week
just really being supportive now that we
have eyes on the situation how's your
week going in LA what are your thoughts
are you Smits Chamberlin I just feel as
though like the more that I've been here
like the more I I'm connecting with Emma
yeah one for me I think that once I go
home like I literally won't give a [ __ ]
but like for now like I have to meet her
but that's so Emma Chamberlain like not
to give a [ __ ] yeah I know totally and
like I went to SoulCycle and like had
coffee so I feel like we don't have many
updates from the last episode because we
went to bed at approximately 8:30 last
night right and we wrapped the episode
we were just so dead LA it's taking the
toll on me physically emotionally
metaphorically spiritually it's taken
everything out of me and like I'm happy
be here I'm happy to give it all that I
have because that's why we came to this
town but I can't believe it's only
Wednesday this is the longest week of
because we came on a Saturday like a
mistake we have done so many podcast
episodes for our practicas for other
people's podcasts I did a [ __ ] live
show like I don't know where where the
world stops and the crazy is for
toasters they've only gotten two
episodes they're on their third and
they're a [ __ ] one right and we
have not stopped but you know what it's
good because our fruit will like will
bear fruit yeah for the next few weeks
as these podcast episodes come out and
I'm actually I feel like I'm getting to
a point where I might be running out of
things to talk about like I did had
their mcdonalds podcast this morning and
we talked for an hour just who is really
great I think it's coming out tomorrow
when this episode airs
I just I'm feeling like I'm getting to
that place you know uh those are always
your famous last words I don't think you
ever talked more on a podcast thing you
did yesterday when you were truly at
your wits end oh really I thought that I
was at my absolute worst with Brad and
Gary like the comments were like Claudia
and you know what people are was a funny
never lets jackie talk to the host and
well that is 100% true i think it's
important for people to know like I just
thought I knew more about Bradley dairy
in that specific episode I was taking a
back seat because I was enjoying like
forgetting to ask questions and also
like you had all the questions and I was
really just learning more about them so
for that claudia was not talking over me
like I was I wasn't trying to you about
that yeah I wasn't I didn't think I was
cutting you off I just thought like no
no it was totally you were driving that
car um but then like that was just that
one time like with Tanya and Beckett
yesterday did we do a good job like did
I say we did a good job I felt as though
I got off my chest everything I wanted
to ask like I was able to find openings
here and there the cutting off like I
guess it's getting to an all-time high
as if I don't realize it so much when
we're doing the show but then when I
watch I get back I'm like what was she
gonna say no as she hasn't me 1,000% in
your famous words I'm going to work on
it I'm more than 100 person so sorry you
know I said if there was a way that I
could stop just know that I would I know
and I'm trying but it's like something
I'm only aware of when I watch myself
not when I'm talking and I actually
notice today on Heather McDonald podcast
I was talking over her as well I think
what I'm going to do in order to help
you is anytime that you cut me off and
like I actually want to finish what I'm
saying I'm gonna call it out if that's
okay okay no holds are accountable yeah
no no no that but I think that'll just
like disrupt the the podcast I'd like
when you were seen on there's gonna be
like I'm not done wait when you were
sitting next to me yesterday okay I
would have loved it look put your hand
here if you had just been like I'm
talking and then you just like put your
hand like for it like give me it like a
physical touch you know no but it's not
I'm just trying to tell you you're
talking too much overall like it's in
when we collide in the middle of the
intersection I'm gonna say [ __ ] I'm
going still straight ahead in the
collision if you could just be like okay
so you want me to just go like that
instead of saying something hit me just
like okay yeah like if I'm starting to
talk over you just be like finish your
son didn't keep talking and touch my
hand okay I don't know how we'll do it
here ally hi hands here the whole
episode okay okay we need a buzzer yeah
yeah yeah or I could just say it yeah or
I combined I just felt like if we say it
we disrupt like the sentence like you
know what I mean like the flow of the
podcasts yes for sure but I feel as
though the audience is with us on this
journey of figuring out how to not talk
over each other you know I'm just gonna
let's take a back seat today I know I
but I really have okay well we have a
great show for you today because
obviously we have the Fast Five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast and then we have a Morgan Stewart
on the show which is just gonna be
premium content and I am so excited but
before we do any of that I think you
have something to say and here's your
chance permission to speak granted
today's episode is brought to you by
daily harvest summer was great but now
we are itching to get back into our
routine after all the barbecues and
eating out during vacations we are ready
to get back to our eating habits of
what's good for us but finding time to
look for recipes get to the grocery
store and meal prep makes it very
overwhelming and that's what's great
about daily harvest they make it easier
to get back into the habit of eating
more fruits and vegetables with
thoughtfully sourced chef's crafted food
that can be prepared in less than five
minutes fill your box fill your bogs
fill your box I'm discussing with more
than 65 different options like ready to
blend smoothies hearty soups and savory
harvest bowls everything stays fresh in
your freezer until you're ready to eat
it their cups take one step to prepare
with room for customization you could
add your favorite milk and smoothie and
blend or heat
servus bowl and top it off with an
avocado or a fried egg living in New
York always on the go got a freezer full
of harvests daily harvest is what makes
being a businesswoman possible it is and
not being in LA and not having my go-to
deli harvests in my freezer is really
hurting me I know I had the biggest bowl
of Bolognese last night before bed know
when she's happy and fries she hasn't
stopped talking but to lunch at the
Beverly Hills Hotel I walked up a flight
of stairs
I was literally winded he was also
scorching hot outside the only harvest
is the quickest the most convenient way
to eat a delicious and nutritious meal
go to daily harvest comm and enter promo
code toast to get 25 $25 off your first
box that's promo code toast for $25 off
of your first box
laughing I don't know why but it's
important because you guys need a you're
not making me laugh
you need a li harvest snitch pipe down
go to jail e harvest calm daily harvest
calm use promo code toast for $25 off
your first box sign on harvest harvest
yourself it's 9:00 on harvest daily
great stuff okay well first story is
little science news sort of because
Bella Hadid has been deemed the world's
most beautiful women woman according to
science like Ann her features beauty is
in the eye of the beholder and
apparently those beholders are still the
ancient Greeks London facial cosmetic
surgeon dr. Julian de Silva has
determined supermodel Bella Hadid to be
the most beautiful woman in the world
based on modern mapping techniques that
implement the classic Greek golden ratio
of beauty fie Hadid was the clear winner
when all elements of the face were
measured for physical perfection de
Silva told the Daily Mail of Hadid who
landed a 90 4.35 perfection score she
had the highest overall reading for her
chin um well the obviously weights 5 is
only 0.3% away from being the perfect
shape so she's number one most beautiful
woman according to science Beyonce is
number two and Amber Heard is number
three thoughts um Bella Hadid be number
one makes me feel incredibly good about
myself because now it's just really
cementing like these beauty standards
like in order to look the way that
everyone wants you to look in to be
perfect like you literally have to spend
years of getting plastic surgery which
is what Bella Hadid has done honestly
Beyonce being number two I feel like
Beyonce is very much
like a natural beauty yeah and it's
actually shocking that someone who's so
naturally perfect would make it to
number two when everyone number one is
literally robot right because like she's
God's work where this is like dr. Simon
ourian right or something and where you
can choose all the perfect features I'm
sure she went by like what I catalog
yeah of like ancient Greek features you
know so I'm glad that all the hard work
paid off and it's like she's number one
and I just I don't I feel as though a
saying that Bella Hadid has had like a
full facial reconstructive surgery like
isn't even a controversial thing to say
like she looks so different like her
nose is different her chin is different
her lips are did her to her her far
heads differently everything is so
different and I'm so pro like surgery
and me doing what you want and it's
obviously paid off she has a huge career
um so I just think this is interesting
who do you think Mike he's them and I
didn't say the plastic surgery thing to
be like a negative no I did her like
it's it's just it's a universally well
known and B I don't think it's a big
deal like I get my [ __ ] tweaked all the
time because I want to feel good about
myself and if I worked in an industry
where my face was my well I don't but if
my face was my moneymaker like I would
go to dr. Simon ourian every day I'm not
saying that in a slight whatsoever I've
been starting to get this like inkling
feeling that I want to get a nose job oh
my god stop are you kidding why are you
taking my thing
no yeah Marcus Louise Romania it's true
get twin noses know what roses from we
all have that ever the family like I
mean how oh my god oh my god Jackie
literally don't even acknowledge it's
not even there yet okay but anyways I
just feel like sometimes like my nose
looks really big in pictures and like
when it or exit don't okay the most
beautiful woman like makes me feel like
we should all be getting surgery but
you're not Avenue but be inspired by
Beyonce who is very much a national
natural beauty and made herself number
two on the list and just for the sheer
fact that she's God's made by God she
should be number one 100 percent you
know what's interesting it's like even
with all the surgery I still feel like
Bella Hadid I didn't know she was such a
classic beauty I think like Gigi is more
of that classic yeah yeah she's not even
on the list that's so interesting so who
do you think is the number one most
beautiful woman in the world I'm sure
I've been trying to honestly I think
kendall Jenner is so beautiful oh she's
not my shadow and she's so beautiful but
she's not like I wouldn't I mean
obviously she's a perfect spot and she
was had that fought for it honestly I
think the most beautiful girl in the
world like this
gonna be so random but like Emily
Maynard Maynard as the bachelor at wow
that's no like you didnt dissapoint like
what I think I'm like she like when she
was master at she was like the most
beautiful person I'd ever seen mm-hmm I
honestly like I'm not gonna lie like I
actually think I'm the most beautiful
person in the world I'm sorry like I
think that I'm [ __ ] stunning and I
have a perfect symmetrical face and yeah
I have a Fupa but like honestly I think
it's beautiful but also they're just
going my face and I think you know why
honey Fupa
I'm like looking at all these girls and
it's like I'm prettier than them I'm
sorry I'm sorry I think you are prettier
than them to you and so are you Wow like
we're so pretty thank you on the inside
too that's true
like I just I think it's important to
calculate that did this doctor scientist
include insides no no it's important
sounds so pathetic to sadness okay me
saying that I'm beautiful like isn't
that funny
x-rays yeah of like whose most beautiful
on the inside I want to know who do you
thinks the most beautiful person on the
inside like oh Tonya rad Jackie I was
literally going down a rad recap having
Tonya and Becca here oh my god well
Becca was such a treat because we
thought we were gonna have Tonya and you
went back in little detects at the text
messages and I was wrong we were so
misled like she said she wasn't coming
but I'm glad she came back she said
there's a chance her flight might get
her in before she could come and she'll
let me know and then she never let me
know so what would you assume she's not
gonna yeah yeah anyways what a treat
that they were both here they're such a
dynamic duo it was so nice to get to
know more about Tonya because I feeling
like I know everything about back up
because she's following her since she
was on Crystal's a season I watched her
and Krista season been seized and I
watch her stories like I feel like I
know her whole life yeah but like Tonya
has is just like always doing new things
and like impressing me in new in
different ways and it was just so great
to get to know more about her and now I
completely understand how she is the
most well-connected woman in Hollywood
yeah because who wouldn't want to be her
friend like next up she's gonna be
hanging out with Kylie Jenner because
that's the kind of friend that Kylie
need that is 100% the kind of friend
that Kylie needs and I just fell after
yesterday's episode we went straight
about it I took my makeup off and I felt
like we had such a great productive day
yesterday like you know like influencing
and whenever but we like hung out
with lady game girls and scrubbing in
girls and I feel like technically you
would consider all of our podcasts to be
competitors but like and that's like the
kind of vibe that Tanya I feel like
injects into other people is like no
it's not like we actually are would be
more beneficial for all of our podcasts
if we all got along and went on to each
other's podcasts and supported one
another and I've never been inherently
that type of person like everyone knows
I'm a very jealous person and like I
won't go on your podcast and don't come
I mind because I don't want anyone to
know but you know like that's the type
of person that I am but I feel like
becoming friends of Tanya right is like
making me a better more modern woman
she's made me definitely want to be more
supportive of other women doing what
we're doing and not that I think of
myself as a not supportive person but I
don't go out of my way to a port plane
either unless did it somehow like
benefits myself but I should go out of
my way so vote for sort someone will go
out of their way for me to encourage
everyone to follow me on Instagram I
Jackie Oprah yeah but Jackie if you're
only doing nice things in the hopes that
it'll come back to you that's not all
the same thing right right so I just
have to like well I have to prop someone
up what so they can get all these
opportunities and stuff that's people
that pass on me for to Jackie but I know
you don't care but this is actually a
very pertinent to one episode of Friends
where um Joey's trying to prove there is
really no such thing as like a random
act of kindness because you're always
doing it for something in return like no
matter what happens that you give to
charity but then that makes you feel
good
but like Joey didn't need Tonya rad it's
very sure you know maybe he would change
his mind he would change his mind but
even in thinking about it like I don't
know how I could just like completely
like I knew I support people all the
time I don't know but then to mention
it's just a tough this industry it's
this town you got down it's hurting me
getting sausage we need to talk like
this I'm supportive left or maybe I'm
Roberta you know I just I don't know I
just think Tanya's like so the extreme
and I it made me realize that I'm not
that person
right and I met I want to be who's in
but I'm not the best and I could be
better I could be more like Tanya wwt D
what we were trying to do that's how I
live my life yeah also if you're
listening to this episode and you listen
to yesterday's episode I really
recommend watching it because there were
so many silent moments where we were all
just laughing that maybe on the podcast
like you thought it was quiet yeah and
also it was just like fun for me to
watch it like for Mike from this chair
like I think you'll really enjoy from
that chair I think you will too though I
mean let's just give it up for like the
toast la vibes oh my god I don't know
how we're gonna go back to ours had
studio yeah like how do we do it without
windows like we need the [ __ ]
sunlight not only
that um I would love to hear the
toasters actually no I changed on it I
don't get back okay are you ready for
our next story always oh this is the big
story of the day you guys Gina Rodriguez
issues second apology for n-word video
in Saturday Gina Rodriguez has issued a
second apology after saying the n-word
in an Instagram video the jane the
virgin star created controversy when she
filmed herself rapping along to the
Fugees song ready or not and said the
racial slur that is part of the lyrics
she initially apologized in a follow-up
video saying quote I am sorry if I
offended anyone by singing along to the
Fugees to a song that I love that I grew
up on I love Lauryn Hill which many fans
deemed insincere as she appeared to
apologize for liking the song and
instead of addressing the implications
of her actions later on Tuesday she gave
it another shot in song or in real life
the words that I spoke should not have
been spoken I grew up loving the Fugees
in Lauryn Hill we we know we heard I
thoughtlessly sang along to the lyrics
of a favorite song and even worse I
posted it she said in the statement
which she later shared on Instagram
quote the word I say and carries with it
a legacy of hurt and pain that I cannot
even imagine whatever consequences I
faced today for my actions none will be
more hurtful than the personal remorse
that I feel watching my own video
playing back at me has shaking me to my
core it is humiliating that this has to
be a public lesson but it is indeed a
much deserved lesson I would love to
know which video she's referring to
there the one of her singing or the one
of her being a [ __ ] [ __ ] right
they both suck but it's worse that in
the second video she had like well the
nastiest tone she ain't had good
intentions and I don't think she didn't
know she did it
did you watch it yes I did know but like
to her that was her apology no I don't
think she was actually releasing it as
she thought I think she everyone in the
middle finger yes like you're upset that
I'm singing a song which is like such an
old out-of-touch response
argument of whether or not someone who's
not black should be able to say the
n-word in a song lyric and it's like we
decided years ago as a culture we're not
doing that like Rhino I don't say that
word when I'm singing and even if I know
that or otherwise that's right ideally
or otherwise oh my god everyone um it's
universally well known that you do not
[ __ ] do that right and you definitely
don't record a video and post it on your
Instagram like in 2019 so to me as as
people who are now experts in cancel'
culture and I feel like if there was
ever an a true Hollywood story about
council culture like we should actually
be contacted like I've been talking
about it so much as we click doing all
these podcast
they are the faces we are the faces I
think there's two major issues here one
on the fact that she did it it's so
crazy to me because she's so woken like
she's really uses her platform a lot for
like really important causes and I think
like a the fact that she didn't know
that this wasn't okay kind of scares me
because she's obviously someone who's
like very in tune right right and to I
think she handled this so poorly because
I only heard about this story when her
nasty video apology came out her being
an [ __ ] made it an even bigger story
and I made it worse for her and made her
crime even worse because it showed her
to be ignorant and not like open to
learning about why that is the wrong
thing to do first she's ignorant and
then she doesn't care and then she and
then she sees and it's it's clear what
happened was after that nasty apology
all of her brands started dropping her
and that's what really made her team
right that she didn't write that thing
right because you when you go from a
video to a written statement it's
because somebody else wrote it for you
right the final statement well I believe
like I understand like people wanting to
write some statements and just like
getting their words out as they come to
them and like I don't I think the fact
that it was a seaman is perfectly fine
but that didn't I say that all should
have been the statement all along it I
totally agree like the fact that she
first did a video and then a statement
really it makes me think that the
statement just wasn't written by her
perhaps because she had she's obviously
comfortable doing a video I know maybe
she just didn't want to put her foot in
her mouth again and like when you make a
video unless you're reading off a
teleprompter you can say anything but
she should never have done a video the
idea was her biggest but aside from the
huge mistake her another huge mistake
was that video the tone was so nasty
he's literally so like I'm rude I don't
know what made her think that was a good
idea her who was around her like telling
her to do that no no the whole thing is
so shocking and I woke up to like my
newsletter this morning they telling me
that Gina Rodriguez has cancelled which
is like words I never thought I would
hear because she's a pioneer like she's
really she was the first Latin person to
be doing a lot of the things that she's
been doing right so and she's always
been so woke like this is shocking to me
like if somebody else had done this like
some like I don't know just like someone
who wouldn't know like everyone knows
this like I know you can't do this right
we all learned from the hendrik Lamar
video yeah Kendrick Lamar invited her
girl on stage years ago to sing a song
with him and she was rapping she knew
all the words and she was white and she
said the n-word and the entire crowd
like was screaming at her and that's
when I learned the lesson
h-he kicked off the stage Island the
lesson because I follow Gabrielle Union
on Twitter and years ago someone
released like a full TED talk just
explaining why you can't do it and I
watch it I was like okay yeah a little
sense like yeah share the link with Gina
Rodriguez it was it was a great video
very informational and educational and
Gina Rodriguez definitely needs to see
it yes so I guess she's on her way to
being cancelled I was never like a huge
Gina Stan no you're not a very big Jane
the Virgin Stan but this is just this
this is shocking it really is is that
like someone so in the know someone's so
popular someone so woke because I was so
many people around her she's getting her
makeup done like there's obviously other
people in the room someone who's gotten
famous a for her talents but really be
for like her activism like I just don't
expect this from someone like that no
like honestly you expect this from like
a reality star who knows no better you
know yeah Gina Rodriguez knows better
definitely
and then it's like it's not even it's
not even a crime but it's also the
cover-up
yes it's always the cover-up you guys
like if I've watched any like TV's shows
enough what would have I been watching
recently oh um the affair like the
biggest lesson in life is call the
police well that's television in general
[ __ ] police said to me call the boys
Jackie chestnut housewives when they uh
spoiler alert killed Gabbi stepdad it
was self-defense called the police but
no you hiding his body under our
construction site in the woods makes it
a crime call the police please call the
Popo okay next up a little happy news
country singer cam is pregnant with her
first child oh my god I follow her on
Instagram and I saw and I just love her
and I cannot believe how far along she
is and how many months she let go by
like we saw at stagecoach seven months
go into his [ __ ] pregnant no one
knew she's no one who's seven months
right good for her I mean that's such a
dream and that that's a dream that we
will never live out because we come on
the show every single day then people
think we're pregnant when we're just
like hungry right but like when we are
pregnant like bro Hashem knock on wood
like May my fruits bare loins made my
loins bear fruit yeah people like how
you can't hide it and you can't talk
about it as a Jewish superstitious
person for these three at least three
months late people are just gonna be
like calling us pregnant left and right
yeah I mean I think this is amazing and
then also Rizzo fans don't also as a fan
it's kind of fun because now it's like
wow Cam's giving birth in only two
months like being on the gyri it's like
I'm at nine months eight months Evans no
it's like now we know and we literally
get to meet the child in two months
right like Amy
Schumer was pregnant forever as a fan
yeah but now like we get the good news
and may get more good news yeah I
actually like an even Shay Mitchell she
did five months so it's like we're
getting five premium pregnant months
she's doing really good content yeah and
then we got a baby yes so exciting it is
how did she keep it quiet like she's on
the road she's touring literally I
follow her on Instagram she has been on
the road since stagecoach all over the
world America Europe Ireland like
everywhere I don't know how nobody maybe
it's just like hard to see from like
when you're beneath like she's elevated
you know also she had a stylist who's
literal job it was to just cover up yeah
yeah well it's an exciting news for the
country music world country music start
cam announced on Tuesday that she was
expecting her first child with husband
Adam Weaver who knew she was pregnant
too out here singing about Jolin who do
that she had husband right I don't know
Julie the news came as a surprise to
fans but the two of that kept the
pregnancy hush for quite some time but
luckily they were ready to let the fans
in on their secret beautiful thank you
for the keep you happy for her don't
worry Hanna
we'll keep your secret [ __ ] hope get
the [ __ ] out of my face hope my
currently my two favorite no you've
closed what's my third it's pretty cool
it's pretty cool we should do we should
do a jingle for tomorrow say mourn and
toast in LA it's pretty cool what with
the snaps in the shoulders read the
statute yeah
the Maureen toast in LA it's pretty cool
it's gonna be like rise and shine kylie
is going viral and so funny the the
YouTube video that she released her
office work came out like two weeks ago
but this one tiny clip of that from that
video has gone absolutely viral in last
24 hours it's been at the beginning of
the video she's like I want to change
Army's playroom but she's asleep we'll
wake her up at the end of the video at
the end of the video she goes in she
turns lights on and she's like French
and it's like she says rice in China in
like a cute like mom jingle way but
Kylie literally has the worst first of
all time it's completely like off pitch
off
razzin chen like that's what it sound
like
and now everyone's like memes of it
ariana grande wants to sample it for a
song it's so funny oh my god that's the
collab we deserve yeah I highly reposted
it was like as long as I'm in the music
John oh my god we need an ariana kylie
collab makeup music music oh yeah yes
yeah
Kylie need to do more collabs with like
more like already a family yeah yeah but
maybe she doesn't want to give them like
that deal cuz it's bad yeah yeah um
totally well our next story
totally totally 100% right yes agreed oh
my god that's crazy
our next story is crazy because Tyler si
is getting ahead of himself
oh my god he's coming for Kanye West oh
oh oh and I personally think that it's
out of control out of control me too so
as you know there's a story going around
where Kanye said that he felt that Kim's
Met Gala look was too sexy and now he's
all grown up any kind of wishes that the
woman that he loves like wouldn't show
her fruits to the world because he wants
it for himself which is right there we
hadn't spoken about that um pullquote on
our show we spoke about on the lady game
and overall though I was like we did
talk about yeah yeah no but we came to
the conclusion that like you mentioned
is how women what to wear but it's
you're right and that's like a sweet
sentiment that you don't want to like
it's just harmless man on the street
shouldn't tell women what to wear but
your husband is allowed to have an
opinion
I haven't thinking and we know then she
has the right to not listen to it he's a
100% influenced by Kanye so he's always
been telling her what to wear and I
don't know I think there's something
really sweet about like him coming up
and like the rap club scene and not
really caring about it and then like now
that he's a family man it's like really
involved in his church like it shows
like an evolution and a growth and I
thought it was kind of sweet I didn't
think it was like disrespectful no and
she has every right to disagree with him
and say [ __ ] you I'm wearing whatever I
want right so Tyler Cameron felt the
need to speak on this issue and he
responded to a tweet about the story and
said what not to do you should want your
significant other to be sexy and feel
sexy yay lost his confidence fellas if
you can't stand the heat get out of the
kitchen why are it's not there's more no
please don't encourage your significant
other to be all they can be not holding
them back
honestly this sounds like a tweet that
Colton would send oh my god 1000% as
he's so cheesy this is so cheesy that
tired you know guys
this is so cheesy and so lame and
remember how like after every episode of
Tyler season he would put up a picture
from the episode and write like a woke
thing about how Hanna's a strong beast
like and I was like a little I roll
worthy but it was like another less like
it was sweet he got like a little too
like drunk on his own like weakness on
his own weakness and its own like
everyone was so like obsessed with his
captions and yeah he took it too far
this time
he took it far too far [ __ ] do you think
you are to go I agree honey not only
that not after Kanye like to get
yourself do you put you publicly as a
public figure now putting yourself in
between I mounted a couple you know yeah
and it's your ex-girlfriends like former
half sister-in-law's husband right right
like stay out of their business get the
[ __ ] out of my face ho it's how I feel
about this and also it's like one thing
to have an opinion like reply to a tweet
about a news story that has nothing to
do with you fine but the already Magilla
this language so fellas if you can't
stand the heat
Jackie get out of the kitchen it was
painful first time yeah it was painful
the first time like honestly I just I
don't like this like at all did you know
this yeh lost his confidence
oh yeah and Tyler she knows that for
sure ya know is that for sure inside
scoop guys and by the way now that he's
not dating TG anymore like don't say
another word get the [ __ ] out of my face
house I'll hide you percent also like we
guess I'll just [ __ ] that up Jackie
we get it you ran the marathon right
here or you're running it Oh what about
New York probably just using around my
birthday it's Jerry frustrating this is
just the tone of like someone who run
the marathon you don't even think they
know everything now right how did he
[ __ ] up gigi hadid but what can someone
clue me in there's a blind about it but
doesn't whine about it but it seems
wholly untrue I really don't think he
was like cheating and stuff yeah and
asking for money which is like he can't
be that stupid yeah no I don't believe
that at all it's crazy I like one tweet
can really change how you think about
someone it's also crazy how one or two
tweets can ruin your life
this is true yes this is true my friend
Jill are you ready for a fifth and final
story no I'm not because I got to let
you know that these jugs are brought to
you by third love hey I'm getting a ton
of questions about the code for third
love because people want to get more
bras because everyone is obsessed with
them so here's the situation
you need a new bra cause boobs look
saggy and you got like a flow over your
fourth cup you have four boot you have
four boom
all about their love uses Oh parents
generated by millions of women who have
taken their fit finder quiz to design
bras with breast size and shape in mind
for a perfect fit and premium feel you
could skip the trip you find your fit
with third loves online fit finder quiz
order try on at home no more awkward
fitting room experiences over 14 million
women have taken the quiz it's actually
fun and takes less than a minute to
complete every customer has 60 days to
wash the bra wear the bra put it in put
it to the test and if you don't love it
return it and third level wash it and
donate it to a woman in need so you can
feel good about your returns and
exchanges they are free and they are
easy it is hands-down the most
comfortable bra that you will own I can
attest to that I wore mine on the 6-hour
flight here and not once did I even
think about like the wire digging into
my armpit and ruining that my gland
loved that wire they're lightweight
super thin memory foam cups mold to your
shape they know there's a perfect bra
for everyone so right now they were
offering our listeners 15% off your
first order go 2/3 love.com slash
morning toast now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love.com slash morning
toast for 15% off today sign on and
chichis up Gigi's up get those sheets up
that's a good reminder for me to sit up
straight as I've been looking like
Humpty the [ __ ] Dumpty on this ship
so props up a throw pillow behind my
back and I feel like a bread nut woman I
need some of that because I've been like
sitting like oh I mean I am just a
grandma and at some point I'm gonna stop
fighting it grandma know you never check
out my shoes okay they can find the
story in a little bit of married couples
fighting news okay Judd Apatow and my
story about me mmm
no because you guys haven't been
together in a few days that's true Judd
Apatow and wife Leslie Mann were seen in
a screaming fight in LA oh my god super
producer Judd Apatow and actress wife
Leslie Mann got into a screaming fight
outside outside la hotspot Katsuya last
night we're told have you miss it I'm
sure spies say that after dinner man was
furiously yelling at the Hollywood
honcho outside the Brentwood restaurant
which is by the way something that we
should do if we want to get written up
yeah while he was trying to stay calm
we're told that Apatow got into their
Cadillac and when man joined him she
slammed the door behind the door behind
her so I guess like a page 6 pie saw
this they run shout to Judd for comment
and he said that was just the fight I
could see yeah you should have heard the
rest
[Laughter]
love that response because honestly to
me like as much as I like live die and
breathe to be famous this probably would
be the worst part it's like and this is
actually what I was saying um Heather
McDonald sent on a podcast today which
was really well said she's like I find
myself like doing and saying things I
probably wouldn't normally do like in a
positive way just because I feel like
people might be watching like I always
now leave a bigger tip and he's actually
had to be nice to everyone because you
never you never want people saying the
opposite about you um and to me this
probably seems like the worst part about
being famous like fighting with your
husband is so normal and if you ever saw
me in bed in like a real fight you would
think we were headed for a divorce just
cuz we're so [ __ ] passionate no worse
than a fight when you're just sitting at
dinner like look at there on your phones
not talking like that's all the time
yeah and if anyone's like picking up on
these vibes it's it's a matter saying
it's embarrassing and so I really feel
bad for them and I'm really glad that
they like made a joke out of it to the
reporter because it's like it's like at
what point like we know too much you
know like it's a consumer like I don't
need to know about Leslie Mann and Jedi
are having a fight at dinner like that's
very Norman at least they're going to
dinner together which tells me they're
still married yes supposed to people who
are never seen together whatever riding
trails just like the fakest people are
the people who like what inside in
public yeah of course you know God and
like me and Ben fight in public all the
time and I'm like so embarrassed because
I got I want anyone to say it just
depends on the public situation like
we're either party and we're fighting
like that's humiliating I know these
people
right if we're in a restaurant there
might be a toaster and she's obviously
gonna be on my side totally a surety
cool get the [ __ ] well with that those
were the past five stories and they were
very fast and I were very five they were
very fast and they were very five and we
rushed right through them because we
have got to get Morgan Stewart she is
here she is waiting for us we are going
to bring her out we have your questions
from our Instagram we will see you in a
minute alright ladies and gentlemen we
are back with a very highly requested
high profile iconic guest the one the
only miss Morgan Stewart host of daily
pop host of nightly pop host of every
realness he knows very well I can
imagine host of what the fashion and all
around like um icon
socialite I want to say am i I think so
I think actually you are the definition
of a modern-day socialite oh my god I
love that 19-4 yeah thank you so may
like Tinsley Mortimer early 2000 vibes
okay but like but like on a like a good
a better luck
like I better like I like tensely though
but I will you know what I mean I guess
I guess I'll take socialite so we've
gotten so many requests to have you on
the show and you're just such a funny
girl you know like you was started your
career out here on a on a very popular
show rich kids of Beverly yes which we
both thoroughly enjoyed do you guys you
guys actually want okay I like I to me
that show seems like a hundred years ago
but yes 100 years right and everybody
went really their own ways like EJ got
his own show Dorothy just jets around
the world where are the rich kids with
now are the dessert group chat are there
there is a group chat i group chatted
with both Dorothy and EJ earlier today
I'm gonna see them Friday Dorothy and I
are very close we talk all the time
EJ and I are very close we literally
live like half a block away from one
another
Dorothy's kind of doing her thing EJ I
think is kind of doing his thing and Jo
Jonny is like a killer travel agent
human being extraordinaire now so he
kind of does that I talked to Johnny
like every other it's always like when
are we gonna have dinner and then we
never have dinner but we'd love each
other what blood and the rich kids
community there is no bad blood I speak
to Roxy every few months
that wasn't question that we got for you
oh god about that so when the show ended
you guys were not going well we were
really true life best best best friends
I mean we were closer than you know
Dorothy and I were and I think the show
probably positioned me and Dorothy maybe
yes you guys did testimonials together
right exactly and we cuz the cut was
kind of the show was around the two of
us or whatever but Roxy was like my true
best friend we were close sisters for
like 10 years and then we had a big
falling out as you guys saw comments
about the house which was like a-holes
she tried to Misha it basically mission
no she didn't do anything actually she
was an innocent bystander she just
wasn't upfront with me about information
that like she knew and we just saw it
differently and it caused this huge
ripple effect and we ended up not being
friends anymore but we have recently
gotten to a place where we are like I've
spoken to her since I've been single
like we've talked about like we are more
than cordial do you think that it was
easier for you guys to get along now
that you are single because the the the
fight involved Brendan I think I think
so I think probably I mean I think we
were cordial before that we had spoken
before that but I think I have just
grown up so much and I was extremely
stubborn an extremely kunti and only saw
things my way back then and I have
learned that there are other people that
can also be right
right and I was not willing to see that
and now I'm like I can't I see that
maybe Iowa came out you a little hard
and I confronted her on the show yeah it
was so painful like I could die which it
was bad I mean this was my true best
friend you if you love somebody but she
had been dishonest with me for a few
months and I knew that you're really
bringing it back up for me sorry I
didn't mean to go here I know I'm you
know what it's nice to be able to just
ramble because I'm he goes yeah no I
hate all the time you need we're just
enjoying that really is maturity
realizing like that person that you're
arguing with is probably not lying like
that is how they perceived it right and
you're not lying that it's how you
perceived it but there really are three
sides to every story yours my god truth
hundred couldn't have said about I never
understood that phrase until like I got
to fight with someone I'm yeah I'm not
long no until Real Housewives where it's
like oh this suppose happened but you're
both just seeing it differently right
totally
so once the show wraps you kind of just
like stayed at E you get started your
career there with necessary realness
right exactly still goes on you did one
today I did once a day yes and it's a
instagrams here if this Instagram series
that's like has a longer version on
YouTube which they love that YouTube
version I'm like do I have to sit here
longer to do this version of this
goddamn show but I love my producer
Vanessa so up Vaness I know she was very
mad at me that I didn't bring the
cameras with me today she's like why
don't you tell me this was happening I
was like I honestly I yeah why because I
was here I've got a lot happening and
ever got so so yes so after richkids was
kind of rapping they came to me they
said we'd like to give you kind of a
deal separately from the show and kind
of see what you can do and that started
with necessary realness and then
coincidentally there was a spot on daily
pop and they were like come hang out and
then they were like come hang out for
longer and like you're really just gonna
be doing this show and then through
daily pop became it came nightly pong
which is kind of like the baby holy
grail whatever the show that like I have
I'm tortured by because I'm like every
other day I'm like that was the worst
show I've ever done no it's so good it's
so good you're me Hannah died I told you
me and Margo were stuck in a hotel in
Vancouver for three nights and the only
channel they had was Ian all they
[ __ ] played was all the episodes of
nightly pop sorry I'm all caught up I
love that yeah you're big in Canada you
should do like a big thing there's
nobody I need to like meet a Canadian
man that's a hockey player oh my god LT
and so we got a lot of questions about
you were on daily pop for multiple days
and then your days went down so you
could do nightly pop yeah okay so right
okay so basically I was due
daily pop five days a week and then the
show we were splitting we were we were
splitting up the shoot days of nightly
pop it's like hard for me to even keep
track and so they took up more than then
I was only able to do daily pop two days
a week now we're shooting all in one day
so I do daily pop three days a week and
nightly pop two days a week but very
shortly I'm gonna be doing daily pop
five days a week and nightly pop I'm
going to be doing four days on Sencha
YES on top of what the fashion which is
now going to two episodes and on top of
that we're gonna do a little necessary
realness so it's really like the ice
cream the whipped cream the fudge and
[ __ ] cherry wow that's amazing it's
amazing but like it's a lot what times
you have to wake up for daily Papa cuz
you guys are three or three hours behind
here 5:30 Wow which people are like but
you leave early [ __ ] you know I don't I
don't I barely and what am I gonna do
run one errand yeah my cleaner I'm a
zombie at two o'clock and I would rather
leave later and get there yeah 100% and
I'm not one of those people they're
people like we must love it no I don't
write love ahead and unlight Lee pop you
have to read off of a teleprompter which
we used to have to do for our show and
it is extremely hard can you talk about
not mean that but please do are you
allowed to cuss on the show yes please
please so that to me I had never so
everybody who works at E for the most
part has had professional training like
they have gone to journalism school like
all of the backgrounds they've done
prompter readings like they've they've
had proper training they literally were
like you're we love you you got to
figure it out and it has been quite the
challenge for me it's extremely hard
it's extremely hard I have recently
gotten into a groove but it's also the
other side of the pendulum where you're
like you're kind of really good at this
but now you're dialing it in and your
original thoughts are lacking so I'm
really just struggling through it for
sure and doing so many hours in content
today like to ever where you're gonna
run out of things to say and things to
talk about
I get so delirious so by the point of me
being like what am i I have a totally
different take and by the time I'm at
that point I'm probably on the right
show so like zero realness is like a
mishegoss of like nothing it's just
nonsense and it's me just basically
being like I need food I'm dying it is
good we talked about Jennifer Aniston
being on Instagram today and I had
talked about that no less than forty
three times and I
she was like so we're gonna talk about
Jennifer Anson I literally was like I
rather have chlamydia and chlamydia
necessary real missed calls for me so
then I basically said that to her and I
was like I'm leaving they're like she's
like do follow-up I'm like no but this
is all you got so what do you think
about Jennifer Aniston being on
Instagram by the way I could talk about
it [ __ ] you see she's at a million
followers like do you only die she's at
nine ten now or something oh my god I'm
just more interested in who she's fallen
I know she's holding six hundred people
yeah like I could be one of that she has
like a millennial intern working for her
who's that coming up with these witty
captions and comments because it ain't
her it is not her right you don't just
get on Instagram and automatically know
how to be on Instagram but the other
thing also is that Jennifer Aniston is
so the person that had a fence duh oh of
course I mean everyone pretends that
they're not interested like Ben and you
know what I'm not gonna say the story
because it's you notice I been recently
went to dinner with you know like a
famous person and was a mess I'll tell
you after and and was like she or he she
or he doesn't want to be like so active
on social media so she does a flip phone
but then she carries around an iPad and
Ben was like she was she gets lost in
the ocean baby Ben was like she's on the
iPad the whole night so it's like she's
got a being on your iPhone and also
everyone can see I'm literally lose your
purse I'm in the makeup chair like
literally like inserting my phone inside
of me what are those hacks like how are
you on an iPod yeah so I just had a
mentality being like so condescending
Levitt oh I'm [ __ ] that everyone cares
everyone can including Jennifer Aniston
including it but I will say I do not
have a fence top and this is where I am
so prideful I will not look if we are
not speaking we have no relationship I
will not look at your page when Roxy and
I stop being friends I did not
I will not peek that's so strong I don't
I don't even cuz I just feel like it
enters my aura and I need to focus on
what I need to get done no it's it's
really like good to be that way I feel
like for a long time I didn't have a
thin so I just made one I always forget
that I have one so I forget to use it
but I just feel so if I want to like
hate follow someone they at least
deserve the follow because that's how I
feel about my hair like if someone like
wants to like follow me just to send my
pictures to their friends and laugh at
me that's fine but can you be 100% the
same way I feel like a lot of people
don't hate follow me I feel like a lot
of people don't follow me and said
[ __ ] around how many Instagram followers
do you have 1.3 you premium content
I booked a little bit more sorry okay so
we had a Malibu weekend together it was
romantic she was like you need to face
two anymore
and it's not that is not true that is
not what I would take your body shaming
we were talking about face soon and how
I'm a big supporter of the app I'm an
ambassador for that you would like just
don't understand it because like you're
perfect and I'm like I'm happy for you
but you were just like I never said that
you need to do it but I was showing you
if you wanted to right here is a
mini-tutorial
this is that her version is the correct
version yes the only reason I do not
face tuned and I am totally for face
tune is because I will go so [ __ ]
insane I will get all that [ __ ] done
before I start smoothing things out
right like I can't start till I like I
had to do a selfie video today I was
like simply videos are actually Harv I
have a dick on my face I do and it's not
even buying me back that's who ad it
sucks I like your nose it's well we're
probably tweaking that shortly but like
a whip it adds character
it does and I and you don't want to be
too perfect like you are literally
perfect like you need to have one
problem it's only fair I'm actually
demanding on behalf of women of the
world that you keep your nose and my
acne I'm getting facial acne do you guys
get that you actually have heard that
like the older you get they say it like
it goes away but it actually comes back
even bigger than better it's weird like
it's been pretty okay I mean I wear a
[ __ ] ton of makeup every single day so
my face is just like yeah but every time
I get a facial now and it's I'm starting
to break out a little bit more but it's
not like it's not acneic it's just like
I have like a few friends that pop by I
understand you know what I mean yeah no
but it's like different than it used to
be that's where I'm at now like my
t-zone is so oily in this town you are
fine she's not your your if you say I
find that I'm fine [ __ ] hair color
[ __ ] I mean what how do we bottle that
up my mom's like all that hair color so
I can't wait so she says that she's you
know she's gonna freak out about it
she's big on instagrams gonna follow you
guys can we talk for a moment about the
legendary website that was boobs and Lou
let's talk about it we used to read it
all the time it was hot layered it was a
mess it was your Instagram handle but
now you're at Morgan circus or a
business lady with your blazer from Zara
can you so cute it's on the app you see
Zara or Zara Zara I think that's right I
think I think it's a New York thing to
say Sarah we don't say it we see Zara so
we would say Zarek's no but yeah I feel
like people in
um like people you're safe there I think
they say both yeah yeah okay I want to
talk about boobs okay let's talk when
did you start boobs & lubes I started
boobs moves in 2010
what place in your life were you out
basically somebody wrote a really nasty
article about me and called me a
cumdumpster
I was like yeah and no and then I
basically just some [ __ ] article
about like just talking [ __ ] about me I
guess people were threatened then
obviously in my mind I was more famous
than than I am now right and so I
basically was like I am a woman
empowered and you can't say this about
me I'm gonna write all about all my own
escapades myself and that's how boobs &
lubes came about it was hilarious
thank you it was a great it was a mish
it was a news accustoms it was a lot
yeah a lot of things were happening a
lot of words were missing but yeah would
you ever write a book I would write a
book
I've actually got that question quite
frequent yeah because you are really at
your essence I guess a writer I am and I
think maybe I would I just don't even
know how to beak the thing about me is
I'm so like perpetually lazy so like I'm
like I'll write that what am I gonna
write that you turn to me yeah how do I
start and we're doing and I'm somebody
like as time goes I don't remember a lot
of things like I'll like move them out
of my mind right yeah preaching to the
choir
it's what's your sign again cancer right
what are you Gemini what are you Scorpio
when's your birthday November 6 ooh
strong Scorpio what are you doing Oh
what's your birthday Oh what does that
mean what does that mean no it's just
horses are strong as well you guys are
really invites cancer in there or vo
yeah cancer and Scorpio are the most
compatible signs of the zodiac what's
been um April 3rd
Aries sure whoo so you're more sensitive
he's more likely so you're from LA which
is why you believe in this trash right
100%
can you explain like when when you've
ever felt like it was just like not
pertinent yeah like give me an example
of realizing saying like I think I have
been I think like just in dating like I
think people like I feel like I've been
with Gemini and Libra are the most
compatible I've been with mainly libras
I did you ever knock about with someone
because of their sign good question
probably really what was that what's I'm
Duffy I would but like I also just feel
like judge I I just feel like I would be
like this isn't gonna work long term
what's the sign that you don't just like
I'm not into a Pisces
what month is that it's like February
early March like those are just too ugly
no one's ever a [ __ ] I never everyone
is a Pisces new I want to have a sexual
relationship with you but Pisces men I
just don't I mean of course if they were
like a gazillionaire and stunning I put
that aside you figure it out but I just
that's not the sign I gravitate towards
um I wanna play a game with you because
okay there was a big post yesterday in
our Facebook group about who the
toasters think that you should date okay
so even gave me love tip I mean it's
just we always try and like match people
up with like successful we just whenever
people like need a boyfriend we're like
we can we can make it happen
you seem like a fun person to setup like
your friends love to set you up no
because I feel like I all my friends are
now kind of in a place where like all my
know while my friends friends and also
my friends now we're kind of all
starting to settle down and get married
now I did things a little bit earlier yo
it's not early no you did early too but
it's we I was just kind of like let's
get this [ __ ] going totally and they're
kind of all in that phase now so they're
useless okay so the toasters are not
useless I just want to just give me your
first reaction like word association
okay
because most people said you and Hunter
oh my god why is your co-host on
Knightley and we we we flirt like cats
and dogs we are never and we are not
gonna fornicate
okay well I'm each other what about Nick
vile do you know him [ __ ] she just
left no no no anyone from bachelor
nation nav nope okay that's a good
question
nope John Mayer yeah I mean I'm I have
I've rescinded now because I have put it
out there so hard Oh have you ever have
you ever met him
uh I've met him yes I have met him in
passing randomly but he's just obviously
too busy on that guitar because he's it
I have done it on daily pop I love you
well I know but clearly he hasn't gotten
the memo and it you have to go and watch
what happens live and then vibe with
Andy and let him know you want to be set
up with John I think that one I haven't
but they started following me on Twitter
so maybe I should tweet yeah here in
that where we should you should when he
went to rest you would be great on that
show - okay well Andy invite me because
I need to sleep with John Mayer he's
really like I don't care about you
everyone's asleep so true including it I
think he likes getting his friend lead
it's a win-win yeah I just want to get
laid by John you're like four times yeah
obviously not the marriage - he's not
mad but you know what
the ones around your arm yeah yeah just
like just like an elitist thing I don't
need singing he's so tall I tall and
just dream and honestly just do it so
like then you could tell me about it you
know that's I have been she had so many
shows happening that yeah okay great
great I'm Tom Hiddleston no why would
you ever be down to date someone you
dated Taylor Swift yes okay I'm a big t
Swift fan oh good
I really am I do love her all her music
I feel like she like sings a blog lyric
or blog no not no not my snow every what
about Calvin Harris yep yep never seen
his penis Calvin Harris's yeah no or I
was going around yeah oh I'd like to see
it I'll show you it's circumsized um I
want to say yeah because I've never seen
a not circumcised penis and I feel like
I would have noticed you know like yeah
the wall same but there was one time
that I was like and then I was like oh
no gotta go
Liam Hemsworth absolutely but he's like
getting it down with that girl she is
cute she's cute and her show is great
but like I think that they really like
each other
I hope so me too do you think that it's
just to kind of get back at Miley no I
think it's convenient though like yeah
happy to be getting back at her but
didn't go out of his way to do so which
is you know what mature yes Michael B
Jordan hot but now Zac Efron hoppin no
what about one of the chris is the pine
Captain America um Chris Pines kind of
oh god mine Emma and me alone forever
who is no one cute to me now okay at
someone actually suggested something
really kind of great for you I'm this
and I have to give credit to someone
named Sam Shoen Bart you need like a
Kennedy or a Vanderbilt oh that's what I
do need yeah I'm very old family I'm not
famous person right Connor Kennedy who
you today tell us we actually tell
ourselves ex-boyfriends it's like a
really eligible group of guys yeah okay
I could do that I think he might be
homeless he's my age just graduated from
college
oh no see I but here's the thing I do we
talk about this all the time my friend
Felicia I do feel like I'm somebody that
could go three years younger or two
years younger if they were serious but
cuz I like that I'm very useful but I
don't but I don't know I would you go 40
but I don't want okay
36 to me is like the age
okay he'll do sorry 31 so that is a good
age yeah
hey file yeah he is very cute yeah this
is his studio yeah he sits here I really
love him he is cute
so Nick call me what's next sign should
we Google it
oh yeah yeah yeah Margot Kyle's birthday
that is so so who is your celebrity
crush when asked John Mayer yeah that's
what I say too else is there and I think
it's totally fine that I say it because
gee did you feel me like been kinda
looks like John Mayer like with the
glasses and everything yes why it's not
guys a very handsome ego Libra is that
good I said Libra and Gemini Nick I told
you I want to be with you that's a good
match for me honestly I think when he's
very handsome I'm not that well-versed
so he was on the back I don't watch him
out on the Bachelorette and then was the
bachelor and really like was one of the
most famous people to come out of it I
think he did too January Jones for a
while and now he's denying but I believe
he's dating Rachel Bilson but he'll hang
okay why don't want to get into no but I
really don't think that they are dating
idea we asked him straight oh and we
meant to ask him off laughter but I do
from I wasn't getting the vibe that
they're actually dating so say he's
single okay well then I'm into can we
get a photo I have like one image I
thought I have one in human maybe he's
cute it was like who was the douchey
bachelor him Fulton you had Colton on
your ship yet no Colton was sweet but
not old and there was another one that
was like Gary
he had like a salt-and-pepper hair no he
wasn't douchey though wasn't there there
was he's huge
yeah this is actually terrible this is
what he looks like that's what he looks
like go to his Instagram that's so me
he's very cute and he's very tall and
strong I think it's a more of an in
person thing but he's very cute and by
the way he might be like she's not cute
like I don't know he would definitely I
don't have good photos online we should
have really like set it up maybe that's
not too late yeah well so many more days
in LA great so let me know okay now I
don't want to go through some questions
that we got for you okay I have a
personal question for you because I like
you are one of the hardest working women
like in modern young people TV I'm
obsessed with the le pop like it's true
i watch it every like day that I got an
answer the toast thank you I love the
dynamic between you and Justin like my
favorite thing and then I love
karissa like being the mom and keeping
everyone on track so I really love like
all three players and I'm glad to hear
that you're gonna be back five days a
week but what did you want to be when
you grow up
this group okay oh no there was never a
and it wasn't even like I want to be on
TV I just was like I need to get paid
for what I'm good at and I'm not gonna
nothing else is gonna work yeah so let's
just make that happen like hosting I was
like the pitlane making everyone laugh
for years for free and I'm like I'm done
oh my god feel that like hardcore
going to dinner and like having to like
keep the party alive like you're
exhausted yeah watch marvelous miss me
so oh my god are you just saying I know
and I have equally good tits yeah and
you know when she like quits the
stand-up in the very beginning and then
it's just like doing stand-up at dinner
parties yes like for free like that's
literally what it's like being a funny
person a hundred-fifty but everyone
staring at you your letter performing
and then you just I go back to the party
totally yeah totally I have questions
from the audience but I wanted to ask
you one more question because you
basically do what we do but I got a much
bigger better scale and that obviously
opens you up to like a little bit more
dangerous situation yeah allows Justin
Bieber coming for you on Twitter oh god
and then our grande also charming it
dramatic then she deleted I mean you
tell me what that was like and what
exactly happens so basically what
happened was I made I will say in poor
taste it wasn't even a funny joke it was
just in poor taste I made a joke about
his acne on his board I was like at
least he got that covered up right or
like any but it was I'm glad everyone
left it wasn't I felt when I was saying
I was like you're reaching right now but
it's stale you're insecure that you're
not doing a good job so you're gonna
project we're gonna make kind of
whatever joke I then got up for daily
pop I was getting ready the PR girl was
like don't answer Justin Bieber's tweets
I'm like I'm sorry I don't know when
that I don't know who's Justin Bieber
what am I supposed to I thought it was
like a group message right and then I
realized that he was tweeting me and I
was like there are so many people that
I've said so many things about you why
are you going to nitpick the one person
that's and I was like clear because he
thinks I'm beautiful 1,000% or that you
have the most impact or something
something he's a big nightly pop thing
and they've hurt him that's what it is
maybe but also which I was okay with and
I let it ride and I was happy to kind of
get the free press or whatever you don't
know it's kind of like don't give it but
then when I started getting my parents
are getting death threat mails from the
Beliebers yeah which I then wanted to
like write like post a photo yes is it
too late to say sorry at first like as a
joke it kind of got a little bit more
and then what I didn't appreciate he's
like let's all just be nice to each
other it's like no you used 12 20 years
and followers on in
Graham you should have used your
platform more responsibility than I
should I totally feel that it's a you
don't get to start something and then
decide that and then by the way you know
it's like stop attacking Morgan when
like that Saturday what you set out to
do or to say stop attacking Morgan yeah
yeah like go you doubt this whole like
you know holier-than-thou [ __ ] yeah
like um you know yeah but it was a good
time like a huge pit near something like
I would have died I I was okay I was
okay
okay I was okay but I was not like you
could take it I could take it it was so
stupid okay something else yes because
on that note like I feel like you're
friends with so many celebrities and
like you see that like you see them work
and otherwise like do you ever feel like
you can't say something about someone
like that you have to filter yourself
because that you know it'll get back to
them like it's a story uh nightly pop
and then they're also your friend it's
really just in deals with that a lot too
I do I feel like Justin's more like that
like I don't know if I'm really friends
with any celebrities it's weird I feel
like I'm a little I feel like I'm a
normal person who just has a job who
happens to be on television I know about
I guess people think it's view me
differently they have you might I'm like
such a normal like inside I've been
going through that this in therapy like
this is different than this thanks Dana
she would've joke to me on text the
other day I was like Dana I can't make
therapy and she was like oh I was like
first she taxed me I got a new phone and
I was like who is this and she's like
Dana with a K I was like Dana Dana with
a k yeah like that was a joke like uh it
was funny hey no it works her last name
starts with a K and then she was like
Dana was again anyway it was it was a
personal moment what was the no that's
it now I just talking about of liberties
oh yeah no I mean like okay Khloe
Kardashian has an example like I
personally love Chloe if I was fake
friends with her I'd probably talk [ __ ]
about her but I'm not gonna talk to it
about her because I love her yeah yeah
and I'm friends with someone you
probably like that mean you don't have
anything bad to say right I'm not gonna
spill their business yes yeah kind of
but you have to Chelsea Handler did that
brilliantly cuz she was best friends
with every person everyone and she still
kind of gave them [ __ ] yeah okay now I'm
gonna take questions from Instagram this
is from Lisbon soon what was your
favorite trip that you guys took on rich
kids of Beverly Hills AHA mosz where'd
you guys say Atlantis I know
no we liked it last we had it was really
not you know there's a lot of things
that are me up here yeah but I will say
I had never been there and it was we it
was the most fun and like I don't know
it was the most like relax like we were
feel it was the most like our real lives
were being captured like cameras were
like floating in the water it was the
best trip we had we all had such a good
time I love the Atlantis did he do the
leap of faith side no course not
no of course are you kidding I bet not
cool on branding no no this is from a
way you did you interview Tyler Seguin
was he flirting with you yeah I think he
was flirting with me a little bit there
was a big reaction to that situation
what did he said he he was just like I
was like it's a cold in here ha like
he's a good hi like he was definitely
very flirty and I was like you're so
beautiful but like you definitely don't
know the capitals of all the states is
that what you said no of course not but
I don't know either so it's okay [ __ ] I
don't know one [ __ ] capital and also
like no diem after like I don't have
time for [ __ ] boys
yeah I actually so funny that you say
that like I met Tyler and Iceland this
is a business thing I want to get him on
the show allegedly well I have a
question for you from Margo there's a
girl who was on The Bachelor who models
Oh Yuri brie guess ya know that she was
on The Bachelor yes and she she on The
Bachelor after she was modeling
she still models for you Craig yes I'd
love Brie and she also like did a great
job on The Bachelor and like represented
the brand really well yeah that's like
just so excited she got her eyes were
longer she might have worn some Morgan
Stewart's for it totally dude she did
she wear it on the show she was on for
one second okay got it
she got another time I love her and
she's just that she looks good in all
the photos so she's a doll Caroline stew
who's the worst person you've ever had
to interview on daily or nightly pop
like who just like let you down or was
rude
oh my god I got this question a lot I
have to say nobody has been rude okay
who's been the biggest surprise in
delight Tori Spelling is lovely really
like random like not the baby's name and
be like a monster actually she is so
lovely so nice like wanted her to stay
yeah hers day I you know what actually
adding to that not she was not rude but
she was definitely I think a little bit
annoyed with us because we asked Tori
more questions but Jennie Garth was a
little I had a mood that day I guess and
it was our fault not hers but she was
probably a little bit marked um question
you are so many people style icons who
style icon who is your style icon who's
on your route okay so Lauren Santo
Domingo obviously from moto operon D
she's not like famous but she's social
ad in New York you will when you google
her I mean like
I'm a very big one of Paltrow Sarah
Jessica Parker Jen Aniston just like all
the classics yeah like all like those
girls rich old ladies yeah I love I love
original thing that is actually very
much here aesthetic yeah some of the
toasters are thirsting out jess rain we
get a promo code for Morgan Stewart
Sport please yeah I'll give you one for
30% off make it I'm on this show if you
make it toaster by the time this airs
tomorrow okay yeah toasters at Morgan
sports - yes bored I'll get you some
stuff and I actually was supposed to
give you guys stuff but the people they
were supposed to drop it off or not are
on vacation so you worry about it this
is a pressing question from Christine
Wilson can we get your thoughts on the
censoring of Jackie shamil's Instagram
did you see all that drama okay yeah but
she's fine now right she's uh no she got
taken off again it's so and then her
backup account got deleted like there's
a lot of time there's a petition going
around and it's because she it was from
when we were all together she was like
filming all of us and was like look at
these [ __ ] and they like deleted cuz
she said horse okay yeah she's at least
rated for [ __ ] and everyone who's
following me should get their [ __ ] we're
all in trouble
100% how does your wardrobe work for the
show oh it's a job for me I go every
Monday and I do polls so a lot of this
so I wear all my own shoes which I buy
and I buy a lot of the clothes so we get
a very teensy budget but I basically I
make I pull rabbits out of hats right
but I do all of my own styling and
people get confused about that I go
every model day that you people style
yeah and we have wardrobe there but I
yeah II was just like it's not good
enough thanks but no things yeah yeah
you never like borrow stepper everything
you have like buy from for the show
right well I shop a lot on my own and
also people send me things and I have a
teeny budget or I'll like do studio
polls but like I I just make it work now
I need to know what is a teeny budget
like like a $2,000 per episode
no like monthly for for how many looks
for daily and nightly brought up all the
like it's all the like teeny budgets
actually I made a budget like I don't
even know if that's actually like the
like I don't even know we're spending
that like right I just threw out a
number that's what to me that's a teensy
budget no that is 4:30 outfit you go to
one event for right spend you can wear
or oh yeah JK I mean that's fair the
core red carpet yeah forget it
yeah but yeah I do um it's al it's a
it's my fifth job we got a lot of
questions about your dog
because we haven't seen them on
Instagram a lot people know okay people
are devastated okay so I took baguette
in Olive is that what they want to know
yeah well both and also where the okay
so but yeah so baguette so but get ran
up to me on the street randomly and she
was an angel straight no gorgeous she
when I we first got her she ran up to me
on the street randomly first and she was
the cutest most adorable puppy and then
Brennan's dad is a vet and they left all
of on her his doorstep at the veterinary
so we adopted both of them I took them
but they live with my parents now Susan
yeah Susan's all about the dogs they
love to send me updates because you're
working when I'm too busy I came a
single parent I basically had to keep
them off the pole I mean they come from
a broken home
I can't believe not one of them is
pregnant every day they're like dad
coming home I'm like he's not Paul one
is contraceptive I mean it's crazy it's
olive you know she's hard that [ __ ]
always opening those legs and it gets so
troubled and angry yeah mom you know why
don't you ask your father speaking of
where is your ring like the most
beautiful thing ever
oh that ring was a good he did a good
job yeah it's in my closet if it's in
your possession it is Oh everyone's you
are you let me know
let me do some ring etiquette if you get
married that [ __ ] ring is yours
if you call off an engagement you give
the ring back but otherwise no I'm
letting it propose to on a holiday then
it's a gift unless you write unless he
leaves you like before the altar or
whatever like it is like that's you
wrong yeah
then you keep it but I there wasn't even
a question about the ring the ring was
the ring is like my my soul do you love
that you had a televised wedding I love
that we had a televised wedding because
we had a great wedding yeah you did yeah
and he looks great beautiful I didn't
look that good but thank you we'll do it
we'll do it better next time umm the
hair was not great and like I I like the
hair and I thought your vows were so
sweet like actually you know that videos
like one of us you watch videos on
YouTube it comes up in my suggested
videos to watch all the time and I watch
it I've never your proposal and then
also your vows there
was very we were actually surprised I on
everything that I've ever loved in my
head about your proposal is he we're
like so there's no okay Matt that was
all it was by the way I was like what's
going on I had not an ounce I had not
one clue he was proposing really I got
not never happens anymore I did you
could I couldn't act that well no it was
really I was very shocked that's like so
nice when someone's able to pull that
off yeah I knew it was happening why
don't you happen and give credit where
it's due
okay last question from Aaron Kunz what
part of your career to date is are you
most proud of
oh my god um I want to say Knightley pop
but just because I've had to work the
hardest at that yeah but not because I
think that that's the best then you do
some red carpet um after shows right for
II do you like those no no I mean look I
like them because they're fun but I just
think I think we're gonna start we did
the nightly pop version of the last one
we did which I think is the best way we
if that's the best way to do that how do
you feel about the fact that like when
people like the recent fashion please
and like Joan we just say like what was
on her mind and like no one is honest
anymore like no one's allowed to be mean
like even if it's true even if it's
funny like how do you feel about that I
feel like you would toe the line best
but like isn't it frustrating when
everyone's like someone could show up
wearing a trash bag and it's like she's
beautiful brother you have to say that
now like I don't feel like I fall into
that don't you don't really don't
straighten when everyone around you is
like maybe I would have just worn my
hair down right yeah of course but
that's why they're not me right so that
should be a benefit to all of it would
you post a new version of fashion police
I feel like you would be excellent at it
totally but I also don't like want to
speak about fashion like in a single
like singularly I want to talk about all
things and incorporate fashion if I just
had to talk about fashion like what the
fashions on snapchat it's very short we
film it pretty quickly so I'm okay with
it but to have to like only talk about
fashion and that's a hard comedy to
because it's like you really do have to
be snarky and also answer from you were
on the Justin Bieber thing we're like
you're now making fun of the way people
look right and that's it that's a big
look I actually think there is no
fashion please right now because our
culture can survive we actually we're
gonna do a pilot for what the fashion 40
be and I think they were like it's just
too snarky it no it is that's definitely
an intern
moment yeah yeah everyone would just be
like getting pullquote
yeah right yeah animals every week
sandals every week but like when John I
used to say that you know Heidi Klum is
such a hot German she looks like she's
about to shove a Jew in the oven like
that was funny that was really [ __ ]
yeah and she didn't apologize but people
tell me sometimes that I'm like Joan and
that to me is the biggest compliment the
ultimate I could like literally just
turn it in now yeah totally it would be
done um we absolutely love having you
you guys we have to do this again I'm
inviting myself please oh my I'm and
anytime you wanna have asked us husband
daily public we are here for you why
don't you guys come on how long a pop
till Friday until Friday okay you give
me a PA la la Morgan on instagram at
Morgan Stewart yes and don't forget to
use code toasters Tom Morgan stats for
30% off yeah well do toaster start yeah
I'll have them doing it yeah okay we'll
post all about it you're the best your
success yeah make sure to follow
Morgan's support Morgan love Morgan say
nice things about Morgan yeah so good
thoughts that Morgan into the atmosphere
yes we will be back tomorrow with
Taoiseach Adams from The Bachelor by my